la vision double la vision troubles
s'étaient et oursins ça me donnait des
vertiges la nausée intense
et loches avec ab quoique pas normal
josé laroche a contracté la coved au
début de la pandémie alors que l'était
bénévoles dans un chu celle des dans les
mois qui ont suivi elle a eu de graves
problèmes de santé
fibromyalgie fatigue extrême perte de
poids et des petits puis des difficultés
avec ses visions une soif constante plus
à l'est les mois passaient la boue sèche
je me levais le matin et j'avais
terriblement soir mais une soif anormal
que j'avais jamais eu
après plusieurs consultations le
diagnostic qu'elle craignait est tombé
un diabète de type 2 mon père a quand
même le diabète et quand j en parlais ça
ressemble pas mal à les symptômes que
moi
gg après les poumons le corps le cerveau
et le foie on constate maintenant que le
corps anna virus peut aussi attaquer le
pancréas ce qui conduit parfois au
développement de diabète on sait que
l'aco vide le virus de la copie peut
infecter directement les cellules qui
sont dans le pancréas et qui produisent
l'insuline qui sont absolument
essentielles pour régler la glycémie le
cas de madame laroche n'est pas
exceptionnel au contraire une étude
récente des données médicales de 200000
personnes touchées par l'aco vide
démontre qu'une simple infections
augmente le risque de développer un
diabète de type 2 de 40 pour ça et de
300% si on a dû être hospitalisé je
pense qu'il est il ne reste pas
impossible que l'aco vide augmente le
risque de développer le diabète mais ce
qui est déjà établie probablement à ce
jour là à la fois par les études et par
l'expérience clinique c'est que l'aco
vide accélère le risque de diabète chez
les gens prédisposés j'ai une fraction
des gens prédisposées très probablement
le problème c'est qu'il ya énormément de
gens qui sont pré diabétiques souvent
sans savoir aux états unis on parle de
38% de la population et au canada de 22%
même si seulement une petite fraction
ces gens-là développe un diabète
précocément il y aura une hausse
substantielle des cas et des demandes de
consultation estime le docteur abbas
alors est le problème majeur qu'on a eu
dans ces deux dernières années c'est le
nombre de personnes qui ont été
diagnostiqués avec un nouveau cas de
diabète qui font partie des nombreux
québécois malheureusement orphelin de
médecins de famille et qui n'arrive pas
à être prise en charge en théorie il est
possible que diabète déclenché super
locaux vides régresse avec le temps mais
pour sa part josé laroche a fait son
deuil on m'a parlé de me préparer
mentalement à ce qu'elles soient touchés
pour le reste les jo cependant malgré
ces nombreux problèmes de santé et ne
regrette pas d'avoir offert son aide
quand les ch et celle des han avaient le
plus grand besoin qui tenu la main
dernier qui était terrifié de mourir
avec la copine
c'était crève coeur je regrette pas le
taquet je leur ai d'ali ici normal
grondin radio canada montréal